if there's a secret to language learning
it's this learn every single day but the
problem is that this is easier said than
done because life always gets in the way
hi my name is Luca from Luca repair.com
and today I'm going to talk about how to
make language learning happen every
single day some few years prior I
finally decided to go around in first
thing in the morning actually at 6
o'clock 6 a.m. it turned out to be much
more difficult than I thought because
what I did is that I woke up and then I
looked at the time and then I have to
put the running suit and I have to
prepare and I had to go running so a
friend of mine just told me one day Luca
why don't you just put your running suit
before you go running that is at night
the day before and I thought about it
and I said oh this is sound advice so
what I did is I put the running suit on
the day before and tada magically when I
woke up I felt like going to run because
I just had to do it I didn't have to
make decisions of whether put the
running suit on or not so a very
important piece of advice and it's not
just valid for language learning but in
life in general divide planning from
executing what I normally do is I plan
my week beforehand either on Saturdays
or Sundays for the following week and
every night after working I just make a
list of the things I have to do during
the following day and of course I do
this for language learning as well for
example I plan my Hungarian lessons I'm
actively learning again right now and I
do that for Greek as well first thing in
the morning between 7:00 and 7:30 that
helps me make the whole routine more
modular more efficient more practical
and I stick to it which is single
handedly the most important thing that
you can do if you want to learn
languages in the long run because
language learning once again is a
marathon it's not a sprint
organizing your time beforehand
organizing and planning the things to do
well in advance has amazing benefits and
amazing consequences one great benefit
is that you can actually foresee and
plan times and activities that really
count there are really priorities for
you when you are energetic when you are
fresh for example language learning
always happens in the morning when it
comes to actively learn a language that
has amazing consequences because when I
do this in the morning my my energy is
very high and I am fresh I am willing
and I'm more motivated while if I did
that without planning maybe after a day
of intense work I would have very low
energy and I'm pretty sure that happened
to you you know you go to work and then
you come back and then you try to hit
the books and then you tell yourself no
this is not gonna happen close the book
end of the deal you don't want that to
happen and for that if you are not doing
that if you're not planning your time
please make a decision and try to start
organizing your time in a different way
if language learning is one priority
then just make it happen every day when
you feel fresh
one of the reasons why language learning
doesn't often happen in the long run
over the long haul is because we start
with a lot of enthusiasm but then we
have a dip in motivation the problem is
that there's a big misunderstanding
about the concept of motivation we think
that motivation will happen all of a
sudden out of the blue we are motivated
but that is not quite true I think that
we have to discipline ourselves to doing
things that maybe we don't want to do
the moment we don't want to do it and
then you know we will start getting
motivated this is what happens and what
happened many times when I wake up first
thing in the morning and for some reason
I don't feel like learning and then I
tell myself you know what can I do to
make it happen
and I found a system I saw it somewhere
and I started implementing it so this is
not mine but it really works so I wanted
to share it with you think about from
five to one and then just do it whenever
you feel like you don't want to do
something either I don't know cold
attacks authorities or do something
unpleasant think from five to one and do
it at the beginning will be very
difficult but if you happen to succeed
in doing this once it will build
momentum and for language learning that
would be amazing think about every time
that you don't feel like learning
five-four-three-two-one
and just do it and again when you build
this discipline that it becomes second
nature and then your motivation will
grow we Italian say la Petite o VN man
John Doe so when you eat you start
getting more and more appetite and that
is surely the case for main floor
so here you have it first thing first
organize your time divide planning from
executing plan on Saturdays or on
Sundays when you have more time and plan
the entire week and every day at the end
of the day plan what you have to do for
the following week this is not just for
language learning but for life in
general the second important factor to
keep in mind is that make language
learning happen when you have energy
when your level energy level is high
because when your energy level is high
you're able to do more deliberate
practice you're more willing you're more
focused and that amount of time becomes
very precious and the third piece of
advice is the following whenever you
don't feel like doing something count
from five to one and just do it no
matter what at the beginning it might be
a little bit difficult but if you
overcome this roadblock then you will
build the momentum and the discipline to
make language learning happen every
single day if you want to know more just
click on the link in the description box
you will be able to read and listen to
an article I have written on this very
same subject once again thanks for
watching and see you very soon on
YouTube
you
[Music]
you